so we've arrived at the functional class
pattern with shared methods or simply
the functional shared pattern but
there's still some cleanup we will
probably want to do before it's fully
refactored for one thing we see that
there are two places that we have to
name the move method once when we build
the function in the first place and
another time when we decide we want to
assign it over onto every car object so
if we found ourselves building more
functions and assigning each one as a
property of the object we would have to
name them in two different places
there would be two lists of all of the
methods that belong on cars this is
problematic because you could easily
find yourself correctly editing one of
the lists and forgetting to edit the
other perhaps there's some programmatic
way that we could iterate across all of
the methods we want to include on every
car object and add them on automatically
as a result of them having been in a
list somewhere there isn't necessarily a
way to iterate over the variables in a
scope and so we're gonna have to think
of something clever maybe we could store
all the methods we plan on adding to
cars in an object in the first place
that way it's easy to iterate over the
object programmatically and add them all
in a single line